hello good morning welcome to Sky News
breakfast a seven-year-old girl is
fighting for her life after being caught
up in a drive-by shooting in North
London Witnesses have described how
people who'd gathered for a memorial
service were sent running and screaming
by the gunshots
Home Secretary swella bravaman says
she's deeply concerned by the incident
we spoke to Witnesses who said they
heard shots and saw a car drive away
from the scene we heard like a loud like
up sound and then but I didn't really
take anything into it and then my friend
was like wait was I gunshot we literally
saw like people are like kids like
running towards this direction so we're
like nah let's come back upstairs
um but then while we were downstairs we
could we literally saw like this black
Mercedes literally sped off
is at the scene in North London for us
now and I should just um bring us up to
date with the latest that we have on the
victims and indeed the suspects
well we know that there were six people
injured in this shooting and we know
that one seven-year-old is in a
life-threatening condition in hospital
as well as that a 48 year old woman is
believed to have sustained life changing
injuries it's an incredibly upsetting
and shocking incident taking place in
this community something that you
wouldn't expect to happen let alone in
broad daylight the incident is believed
to have happened Saturday afternoon
around half past one is when Emergency
Services were called and the
Metropolitan Police say that it was
believed that the shots were believed to
have been fired from a moving vehicle in
the vicinity of a church where a
memorial service was taking place now
the local MP and labor leaders
has reacted to the incident on Twitter
he tweeted I am deeply shocked by the
shooting in Houston and want to thank
the emergency services for their
response my thoughts are with the
victims so there is still very much
strong police presence here according in
place here on Phoenix Road and also
backing onto evershalt Street as well as
please continue to investigate the term
to determine exactly what happened there
appealing for any information that's any
video footage any CCTV anyone may have
to help determine and put together the
events that took place yesterday
I sure thank you
Ukrainian officials say at least 14
people have been killed by Russian
missile strike on a residential Block in
dinipro rescue workers have been working
in freezing conditions to recover people
from the wreckage including more than 60
injured the knee Pro was one of a number
of cities targeted by wave of strikes by
Moscow yesterday night
or meanwhile Britain has made its first
commitment to send tanks to Aid the war
effort as our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes reports
Holmes crushed in a Russian missile
strike far away from the front line
[Applause]
this Horror in Disney Pro was condemned
by Ukraine's president who stressed the
need for more powerful Western weapons
to help his troops win
this is the kind of weapon he has in
mind
Britain's Challenger 2 main battle tank
pictured here exercising in Estonia
in his phone call with Vladimir zelensky
Rishi sunak pledged to give 14 of the
tanks to Ukraine
the number is small but the move is
significant marking the first time
Ukrainian troops will receive Western
tanks
the UK also plans to supply Ukraine with
more artillery
30 of these as-90 self-propelled guns it
shows that we are now Less risk-averse
in a grading our support for Ukraine
less spooked I suppose by Putin's
rhetoric that any serious Western
involvement could have repercussions in
the war might dangerously escalate
Russia was quick to issue a warning
saying bringing tanks to the conflict
Zone far from drawing the hostilities to
a close will only serve to intensify
combat operations
one of those most wary about escalation
is this man Germany's chancellor Olaf
Schultz on a visit to Kiev last year
yet he's under growing pressure to allow
german-made tanks to join the fight
it's not a done deal yet but the UK has
just made it a bit harder for Berlin to
say no debraham Sky News
[Music]
or you can use this morning at least 16
people have died in a plane crash in
Nepal a passenger plane carrying 72
people 68 passengers and four crew
members went down in Pokhara in the west
of the country a spokesperson for the
airline operator Yeti has said there
were 10 foreign Nationals on board
authorities are working through the
wreckage of the aircrafts which had been
on route from the capital of Kathmandu
we will bring you the latest as and when
we get it
nursing union leaders have warned that
twice as many nurses will go on strike
in early February unless there's
progress in pain negotiations the head
of the Royal College of Nursing says the
prime minister's position over the
deadlock in talks is baffling and
Reckless our people in politics
correspondent Nick Martin has the
details
well this is uh clearly an attempt by
the Royal College of Nursing to pile on
the pressure onto the government to try
to come to some kind of resolution in
this dispute the Royal College of
Nursing have said that if they cannot
come to an agreement with the government
then they will potentially double the
amount of nurses who will be eligible to
Stage strike action in early February
now that could have a significant impact
this potentially could make the
government sit up and listen Pat Cullen
the General Secretary of the Royal
College of Nursing has made no secret of
the fact that she's not happy with the
way the government have in her words
showed lack of engagement on this issue
um writing a being quoted in in a
newspaper today she says Rishi sunax in
transience is baffling Reckless and
politically ill-considered the nurse
shortage costs lives sunac could not put
a price on a safe NHS now the demands
are are quite significant the Royal
College of Nursing are asking for a 19
pay rise something the Prime Minister
has called quotes obviously unaffordable
but nevertheless the strike dates are
going to continue nurses expected to
walk out next Wednesday and Thursday
then February the 6th now in the
meantime an interesting story in the
Observer Today the health secretary
Steve Barkley reportedly having private
conversations with the unions in which
he has been encouraging them to put
pressure on the treasury and number 10
to press for more money that might
enable some kind of an agreement Sarah
Gordon the head of Health at Unison one
of the biggest Health unions said that
on a meeting last Monday Steve Barclay
has talked about them asking to make the
case to the treasury now the problem
here is that the treasury hold the purse
strings money has been allocated to the
NHS this year this could be a sign that
Steve Barclay is willing to compromise
but he knows the reality is that there
could only be a resolution if there is
more money in the pot
I think Martin while teachers in England
have reportedly backed plans to strike
next month the National Education Union
balloted 300 000 members and the Sunday
Times says the results is in favor of
strike action the union has not yet
confirmed the result which will be
announced tomorrow
this morning Sophie rage will be joined
by the transport secretary Mark Harper
the shadow Northern Ireland secretary
Peter Kyle Dr Philip Barnfield of the
British Medical Association and the
chairman of Tesco John Allen that will
be this morning from 8 30.
foreign
brought to you earlier and at least 16
people have died in a plane crash in
Nepal a passenger plane carrying 72
people 68 passengers and four crew
members went down in Pokhara in the west
of this country
spokesperson for the airline operator
Yeti has said that there were 10 foreign
Nationals on board
and the latest we have we have heard
from a Nepal airport official that there
were five Indian Nationals four Russian
Nationals one Irish and two South Korean
and also one Australian one French and
one Argentinian Nationals on board the
authorities are currently working
through the wreckage of the aircraft
which had been on route from the capital
Kathmandu we'll bring you the latest as
and when we get it
thousands of protesters have gathered in
Tel Aviv to Rally against the new
government's plans to overhaul the legal
system prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
launched proposals to weaken the
country's Supreme Court by giving
Parliament the power to overturn Court
decisions with a simple majority vote
remaining authorities have seized cars
belonging to the British American
influencer Andrew Tate Tate was detained
last month on sex trafficking charges
police took 11 limousines two Mercedes
and a Rolls-Royce from his property near
Bucharest
drivers are being warned to expect to
see a growing number of potholes due to
the large amount of rainfall either side
of last month's cold weather the RAC
says December created the perfect recipe
for potholes to start pepping the robes
but the department for transport says
there's a potholes fund
the O2 Academy in Brixton says it's
going to stay shut for another three
months this is after two people died in
a crowd Crush there security guard Gabby
Hutchinson and Rebecca ikumelo were
killed when crowds which included fans
without tickets gathered at a show by a
singer a Sharky at the venue last month
the nephew of a British Iranian man
executed in Iran has described his
killing as a political game
Ali rezva as khabari was sentenced to
death on charges of spying for the UK
after temporarily recalling the
Ambassador the British government is now
considering what further action to take
against the regime John Sparks reports
the facts are disputed but the
consequences are clear a national of
Iran and Britain alireza akbari was
executed
news of his death was broadcast to the
country on national TV
Mr ackberry was one of Britain's most
important spies says this presenter he
knowingly sold Secrets abroad a claim
that is vigorously disputed by his
family it is a political game it was a
political game he
he was somebody that was involved with
the regime from the very beginning of
its foundation he was holding senior
positions somebody like that was
dedicated
to the country uh and to the regime
he was arrested in 2019 but details of
his detention and death sentence were
only revealed this week
Iranian television had the story however
broadcasting this obituary
we see akberry in this meeting
reconstructed for the cameras speaking
to a British agent wearing a blonde wig
finally the former official is seen
signing his confession papers although
he told family members on the phone it
was forced by means of torture this is
the first time in decades that a senior
Iranian official has been hanged akberry
charged and executed for corruption on
earth a catch-all for crimes like
treason
for others have been executed after
their involvement in anti-government
protests this time for a Waging War
against God and some think the two are
related akbarry's death a means to
deflect attention the regime does
anything that he can unfortunately to
suppress the the population but also to
the distract the global
perspective on what is actually
happening to to to the to the people in
the country
according to the British government the
regime is responsible for heinous human
rights violations and it has responded
by temporarily withdrawing the
Ambassador we take this incredibly
seriously and of course we will make
sure that we respond to deter any
further actions like this being taken by
the Iranian government yet The clerics
Who Run Iran will not give way
voluntarily as they deal with their
purported enemies at home and abroad
John Sparks Sky News
Dan plays she's professor of diplomacy
and strategy at soas University of
London it's great to have you here on
Sky News thank you very much indeed now
talking about Mr akbari he worked for
the regime for decades his family says
he was committed to it so shouldn't that
have provided him with a certain level
of security
well it did uh might be expected to I
think that if we're looking at the Mr
agbara's nephew I think described the
situation very well
um
unfortunately I think the British
government's reaction has not been the
wisest uh the most important thing the
British government has done with respect
to Iran recently is to council uh BBC
World Service Iranian service which is a
crucial soft power measure to uh
communicate with the people of Iran who
are in a uh a situation of increasing
revolt and Revolution against the
Hardline regime and then Mr cleverly and
Mr sunat really wanted to influence Iran
and they would redouble the uh output of
the BBC person service and possibly our
television Dimension rather than
engaging in this extremely inflammatory
rhetoric and if I may Vanessa the
rhetoric coming from the British
government really dances to the regime
in tehran's tune because they want to
have Britain as the bad guy making a
huge fuss uh and by making a huge fuss
uh reinforcing their line about
Portman's struck Bari so from a
diplomatic perspective of what the UK
government is doing is very
counterproductive
well let's explore that line further
than what you were just saying about the
British government's response not being
the wisest what further actions do you
think that we should be having you have
alluded to some of them but what do you
make of the sanctions that have been put
in place currently how much further
should we be going well if you had to
choose between restoring and expanding
uh BBC World Service uh she's been over
on sky here but uh
restoring and expanding BBC
transmissions in Persian and Arabic uh
is probably the most important thing one
can do to support the uh heroic women
and others of Iran uh by providing a and
keeping uh going uh this vital
Communications Tool uh whereas if
another round of sanctions someone has
to ask after all these years quite
um what further sanctions can be
effective
um the communication strategy would be
more it would be more a useful uh
targeting a particular prosecutor while
it's better to uh contact uh and Target
particular individuals that entire
populations that is more effective but
in general uh using words like barbaric
after all our closest allies the United
States and Saudi Arabia for example do
execute people so quite what is barbaric
beyond the fact that these are
presumably trumped-up charges or that is
the allegation but this kind of language
plays into the idea of the evil Britain
interfering once again in Iranian
Affairs and the narrative that the
revolution against the hardliners is
somehow orchestrated from outside
and so it begs the question what is
Iran's motivation then behind this
killing because obviously they know that
this was Sour relations
well Vanessa I think the uh uh the poor
gentleman's nephew I think put his
finger on it quite probably which is
that the
the regime wants to uh portray the UK
and the us as always as the evil enemy
and so uh this execution and the
broadcasting of Presumed
um but possibly fabricated confessions
and so forth feeds into that narrative
that he's an evil British agent
um and that it's Britain and its allies
who are to blame for uh the situation in
Iran and that people protesting against
the regime are somehow tools and by
using the most inflammatory language
externally one is simply dancing to that
tune so it's very naive I think from the
from Mr cleverley and Mr sunac
Dan pledge she's professor of diplomacy
and strategy at soas University of
London grateful for your time thank you
thank you Vanessa
now some more breaking news on the plane
crash in Nepal this morning and the
country's Aviation authorities have
revealed that the death toll has gone up
40 bodies have now been recovered from
the wreckage the aircraft have been
carrying 72 people 68 passengers and
four crew members which went down in
Pokhara in the west of the country
spokesperson for the airline operator
Yeti has said that there were several
foreign Nationals on board we have heard
from a Nepal airport official that they
are five Indian Nationals four Russians
two South Koreans and Australian a
French national and an Argentinian as
well as an Irish National
here are the latest pictures then that
we have from the scene as you can see
smoke billowing there authorities are
working through the wreckage of the
aircraft which had been on route from
the capital Kathmandu we are staying
across this story for you and we'll
bring you more as and when we get it do
stay with us for that
foreign
flood warnings and alerts are in place
across the UK a yellow warning for ice
is also in place across Scotland and
north of England with a cold front set
to cover most of the UK next week well
let's bring in our skies meteorologist
Kirsty McCabe and Kirsty it's not
sounding good on that um cold front
there just give us more details on what
we can expect and when
morning Vanessa it's not going to be as
intense as the cold spell we saw last
month but it is set to turn much colder
and quite a change compared to the wet
and winding quite mild weather we've had
of later it's good news though for those
areas affected by flooding there's
lettering on the forecast but it is
going to turn much colder and let me
show you why it's all down to the jet
stream now normally this Zone a very
strong winds high in atmosphere moves
fairly west east across the UK it's
going to be buckling further south of us
as we head through the next few days and
as it Dives South towards Europe it
drags in much colder Arctic air from the
north so although the weather is going
to be settling down it is going to turn
significantly colder as we drag in this
cold Arctic air mass so you can see the
blues on the chart and that means we're
looking at Frosty conditions ice as
you've mentioned risk of snow as well
we've got some snow showers coming to
Northern Scotland today we've got some
rain and wet snow and sleet further
south across parts of Ireland Northern
England later into Wales and
temperatures today well around say 5 5-7
South East and a widespread for us
tonight as you mentioned that ice
warning is in place temperatures could
be as low as minus 12 in the sheltered
glaines and the cold weather set to stay
until at least Thursday and that's when
we should see milder air returning from
the west but could bring some snow with
it first oh my goodness Kirsty thank you
welcome back Chinese officials say
nearly 60 000 people with covid-19 have
died in hospitals since it's dropped to
zero covert policy last month the
admission comes following criticism of
the state for not releasing accurate
coronavirus data since the policy change
will joining me now is Dr deep sea
godhasani who is a clinical
epidemiologist and Senior lecturer at
Queen Mary University of London
um thank you for your time this morning
what are the ramifications of China
lifting these sanctions are we likely to
see new variants emerging
I mean it's entirely possible what we've
seen here was entirely foreseeable we
saw a country a large country which had
a zero covet policy which was maintained
largely through lockdowns masks and mass
testing move very quickly to essentially
lifting all mitigations and what we've
seen is mass spread through the
population so I think it's estimated
that 900 million people in China have
been infected and we know that as a
virus moves and transmits it has uh you
know it mutates every time that it
transmits and this provides huge
possibilities for the virus to mutate
particularly in a background population
that doesn't have a high level of
immunity to the virus while vaccination
rates
um overall are high in China we know for
example that they're quite low in the
elderly population so the high number of
cases has predictably you know
translated to a high number of deaths
and we expect the death figure is to
continue to rise and potentially the
actual number of deaths could even be
higher than what the official estimate
state
and China reporting 60 000 deaths since
lifting a zero covered policy I mean how
worried should we be by these figures
coming out of China and indeed many of
those many people question those figures
coming out of China many fear that the
number could be higher
it is very concerning and before this we
were told that they'd been about five
thousand dead so there's been a huge
sort of jump in what we're being told
and 60 000 deaths in a very short period
of five weeks and itself would be very
very concerning but it's very likely as
you say that the figures are actually
higher because we haven't had a lot of
transparency from the government during
this period uh they're not actually
reporting the exact number of cases
every day we're not seeing absolute
number of deaths being reported on a
daily basis rather we're getting this
sort of official news at particular
intervals which shows sudden jumps in
the number of deaths Meanwhile we're
hearing within China that hospitals are
being overwhelmed in some places but
there's very little news that's getting
out of China so it's very hard to know
apart from the official estimates what's
actually going on
and in the UK I think many people appear
to think that the era of covert is
behind us but the reality is that it's
not are we in danger of being complacent
ly I mean what we're seeing in the UK
I'm not just the acute impacts which are
significant I mean you know on the crown
which is deemed mild caused more than 33
000 deaths from covet in 2022 but we're
seeing an era of chronic disease so we
are seeing for example 2 million people
now living with long covet a large
number of those have had illness for
more than a year or potentially even two
years uh we are seeing excess debts
every single week so for example in the
last week of Christmas we had 3 000
excess deaths some because of covet some
because of flu some potentially because
of long-term impacts of covet and some
because of the huge pressures on the NHS
and the breakdown of the NHS which is at
least partly related to the pandemic and
the continuing high level of
hospitalizations and infections that
we're seeing within hospital with covet
and what lesson do you think that we've
learned from the heights of the pandemic
or at least should have learned from the
highs of the pandemic that we should
avoid repeating
I mean I don't think enough lessons have
been learned because I think the lesson
that we should be learning now is this
living with its strategy isn't working
we had five waves in the UK in 2022 and
all of them were associated with
significant disruption to the Health
Service significant number of deaths as
well as huge chronic disease burden I
mean this is a disease that affects
every single system of your body long
term so what we need to be learning is
what we need is air quality regulation
we need to adapt to the virus letting it
spread is not living with it we need air
cleaning air sterilization Technologies
we need infrastructure to allow for
better ventilation we need to change our
lifestyle to be doing more Outdoors we
need people to be wearing well-fitting
high quality masks that really reduce
the spread of the virus and we need
testing and support with isolation
provided by government alongside
vaccination the government has
unfortunately adopted a vaccine only
strategy that has led edged us to where
we are which is still continuing to have
high numbers of deaths and high levels
of chronic disease and huge pressures on
the NHS all of which is unacceptable
it's got a signing thank you very much
indeed
nearly 60 of unpaid carers are
struggling to make ends meet a recent
report from the House of Lords says
unpaid carers are filling the void in
Social care but during a severe cost of
living crisis many households are being
badly affected as Molina vaselinovich
reports
when her mum got sick Denise gave up her
job to look after her but that also
meant giving up her livelihood and with
no financial support from the government
her savings were quickly drained we rely
absolutely holy and solely on mum's
state pension and her disability
benefits not building up any savings
you're not paying anything into a
pension fund
you are thinking well what what happens
and also what what what happens when
when mum does pass there's another one
concerns shared by millions of other
unpaid carers who like Denise can't fit
work with caring though their labor
campaigners say props up Social care
the system would absolutely collapse
without unpaid family carers at seven
million across the UK and they are
providing all manner of support and
otherwise people would be in hospital
they would need far more help from local
government from social care sources
despite that about half of unpaid carers
don't get any state support and those
that qualify get just under 70 pounds a
week compensation that PSA doesn't match
their contribution
unpaid carers are filling the void in
government social care according to a
new report by the House of Lords and
that is putting Financial physical and
emotional pressure on those carers who
the report says are at a Breaking Point
but the government says they are giving
support telling us in a statement since
2010 we have increased carers allowance
putting an additional 800 pounds a year
in Kara's Pockets while the amount
someone can earn while remaining
eligible for the support has increased
by around a third in that period
the cost of caring though is not just
Financial I always feel very guilty
that she's had to give up so much for me
she's not got any social life she's
hasn't had the prob the prospects
of of her career as as she could have
had she has had to give up an awful lot
for me
a feeling of guilt that many of those
cared for share
Sky News
watching Sky News breakfast coming up
we'll be taking a look through this
morning's papers for the help of the UK
editor of the big issue magazine Paul
McNamee and sociologist Ashley Frawley
[Music]
welcome back plenty to talk about in
today's papers joining me to go through
them UK editor of the big issue magazine
Paul McNamee and sociologist Ashley
Frawley is great to have both of you
back with us let's dive straight into
this because this is just far too juicy
and we have to talk about it so um Paul
let's go with the front page of the
Sunday Times the headline there we can
see Johnson had credit facility worth up
to 800 000 pounds while in Downhill
Street so many questions going on here
firstly who has eight hundred thousand
pounds to just give away and what do
they get in return just spill for us
well according to the the Sunday Times
um this is a chap called samblay who's a
Canadian businessman he is the founder
of Canada's biggest team of private
schools and he is a distant cousin of
Boris Johnson who wouldn't like a
distant cousin the on the right there
their lifestyle uh with this story it
says that um he also had this Dominican
Republic villa which he gave Boris
Thompson for free to use which is
normally five grand a night again who
wouldn't like to have use of a five
grand a night fella I think
interesting about this is they said that
Johnson was used he used this to pay for
everything everything from divorce
payments to child care costs and it it
it it speaks to this particular idea of
a in a sense of entitlement that some
people believe Boris Johnson had like
some kind of evil and War character and
also given that we have heard this
narrative start to play out the Boris
Johnson perhaps is waiting for his great
comeback he's waiting for tonight to
feel and then he'll he'll come in like
the um the the hero of the piece he
knows exactly that's true but it's
certainly something that's been played
out
well why would why would anybody want a
bag if he lives in this kind of
Lifestyle where he doesn't take
responsibility for anything and just
goes to this massive credit card it's a
significant story we don't know how much
he drew down
um over the two years or so that he was
in Downing Street but he had this
ability to get Murray it sends at the
drop I have when he wanted which also I
suppose takes into the normal lifestyle
that a lot of people are facing the cost
of living crisis absolutely and a lot of
people don't have that distant cousin I
mean I wonder if we're all related to
him maybe we should start looking into
our family tree you never quite know do
you
um actually let me come to you this this
is a very um serious story on the front
page of the Sunday Express there that
headline we can see their spelling is
out sex assault during riot at Migrant
Center
yes that's right the Sunday Express is
reporting that uh on claims that a
Migrant Center worker was assaulted
during a riot at Britain's largest
immigration removal Camp last November
um they also report that some refugees
um at the center have tried to keep the
peace and attempted to protect staff as
Mayhem Mayhem broke out and this is from
a home office report that the Sunday
Express has requested
um you know this all happened when or
after staff had requested
um to evacuate detainees after a loss of
water and electricity and they were
refused and it's really worrying that
these kinds of awful incidents might be
used to fuel further migration Panic
which in turn gives impetus to ever more
inhumane policies aimed at migrants
attempting to deter them so the idea is
just to make people's lives as brutal as
possible to try to stop them from coming
to the UK but study after study has
shown that it doesn't actually work and
all that it does is create worse and
worse situations and it creates
situations like this where workers in
these uh centers are put in danger
dealing with people who are pushed to
the absolute Brink
um and it puts people in migrants in
dangers they try to cross and enter into
the UK use via more and more difficult
channels it creates this kind of vicious
circle where more and more Panic is
stoked and this feeds more and more
brutal policies and it's got to end at
some point we have to realize that it's
it's government policy migration policy
inhumane migration policy that's causing
this and um moving on
um to the next story also in the
Observer actually this is on page three
of The Observer Paul Whitehall spending
tens of Millions on Bill to scrap EU
laws should we be worried
well I think of if we are worried about
massive government overspending when it
isn't essential then yes because what
this is this is looking at I suppose the
brexit cost everything comes across and
when there's rhetoric from government
about how they're going to get rid of
red tape which is always just regulation
this is this is the reality of it
according to this story
um million tens of millions have been
spent on the bill to scrap the EU laws
that is currently going back and forth
between the um the Lords and the commons
and the return to EU laws built uh
there's about 4 000 pieces of
legislation uh and laws regulations that
have got to be got rid of and I suppose
replace something this story relates to
um the Department of Business energy and
Industrial strategy it admitted and
spent 600 000 in Staffing costs in the
last couple of months to try and find a
way to get rid of these these laws and
regulations however that's less than 10
of the total that need to be got rid of
so you can see how this starts to factor
up other government departments have
been told they can't give this
information
so yes we should be worried while um the
southern lit Uplands
of brexit are definitely not forthcoming
there's also another cost of
um trying to rule out our separation
from the EU and this is just the start
of it we don't really know the cost yet
the full cost whether it's Financial or
social
and um Ashley let's talk about the NHS
and this also talk about social care
because at the time when spending for
both of these areas are very very tight
a story like this isn't going to sit
very well with many people so also
staying with the Observer paid for their
private Brokers earn Millions from
finding care homes for NHS patients how
have we even got to this stage in the
first place
foreign
from earlier underfunding in Social care
so part of the issue is that hospitals
are struggling well part of the the
reason why hospitals are struggling
um at the moment and you've seen long
wait times
um long times in ambulances is because a
third of hospital beds
um are occupied by people who are well
enough to leave hospital but because
there have been difficulties identifying
social care uh social care support
they're not able to to leave and so
these agencies have come in which
promised to free up beds and Hospital
Wards now usually this is just done by
hospitals themselves where they will
work with
um local areas and work with local Care
Homes and and and social care to
discharge patients but these agencies
have come in and said that they do a
well they claim that they do an
essential service and that they do
things quickly and efficiently
um but of course one The Observer is
recording that one such company Care
Home selection limited um the UK's
biggest social care brokerage has
reported revenues increasing by up to 75
percent since since 2018 and that they
paid their most senior directors 609 000
pounds in 2021 and there are accusations
that there a lot of money is you know
they charge a lot of money for these
services that might have better been
spent on better planning previously on
social care so we didn't have this
problem in the first place it seems as
though there's a lot of willingness just
to overspend or to spend quite a lot of
money on these kinds of agencies and
services and less willingness to spend
on training and actually paying people
to do an essential service in the
community which is social care
and um this is a story that the headline
Paul's making me laugh this next story
of page five off the mirror
um the this is the rise in prizes for um
highs there the bean counters Heinz
price rise puts the wind up Shoppers I
mean I I personally I'm not a beans fan
but we also have to say there are other
beans available there's also
supermarket's own brand isn't there I
mean why are people so angry about this
so much is going up right so
what makes Heinz any different
this is a story that seems to have been
written just for that subtech headline
just so that
um they can have the idea of wind
attached to the bins because
it's been going on for over a year that
particularly Heinz and the price rise of
Heinz beans and how
some people are very attached to their
beans and particularly hands there's a
lot of brand lightly and you're right
there are
Brands as well
we're just running out of time oh the
wind just so what a shame thank you so
much indeed Paul and Ashley thank you so
much we'll see you after this break
thank you